[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Welcome to "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
Machine learning
continues to be applied
to use cases across industries.
The airlines and transportation
industry is no exception.
I'm thrilled today to chat with
Ksenia Khlyustina, a machine
learning platform
manager at FLYR Labs,
where her team leverages
data and machine learning
to help airlines better
forecast demand, set prices,
and optimize revenue.
I'm particularly excited to
also have Ksenia give us a peek
into the core components of
FLYR Labs as ML platform.
Welcome, Ksenia, and
thanks for joining today.
Can you start off by telling
us a bit about yourself?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Sure.
Hello.
Yes, my name is Ksenia, and I've
been with FLYR for three years.
So in general, I have
about eight years
of experience in the
industry in multiple domains.
But, however, I started
working in machine
learning only three years ago.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
And now, can you
tell us a little about
your company, FLYR Labs?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: FLYR Labs
is a company been bringing
intelligence to airlines.
So we are trying to
use machine learning
and AI to be able to
predict demand and optimize
the pricing for the airlines.
So we want to make sure that
every flight, at takeoff,
is 100% full and bringing the
maximum revenue to the airline.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Oh, wow, that's great.
And that field is especially
particularly relevant
and important today for
the airlines industry
in the midst of the pandemic
and now how consumer behavior
changes really, really fast.
So now we are here
to talk a little bit
about machine learning.
Could you discuss some of the
top use cases ML is applied to?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: We basically
have only one use case for now.
So we are taking all
the historical data
from the airline.
We're taking their
competitors' information.
We are taking information
about future events
at the origin or
destination of the flight
and putting this
all into our models
and outputting the
demand forecasts, which
are used to optimize the
pricing and deliver this
to the airline that are lightly
used in their production
systems.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: And before
we dive into that use case
and how you've architected
a platform around it,
I think I wanted to dig a
little bit deeper into your team
and how it fits within the
broader FLYR Labs organization.
I think a lot of
companies today,
they might only have
one data science team.
They struggle to
operationalize ML models.
Could you talk a little
bit about your team
and the other teams at FLYR
that are tackling this problem?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA:
Yeah, so FLYR is mostly
built around the design.
So of course, we have more
than one data science team.
We have a data
science organization,
which my team is a part of.
So this data
science organization
consists of three teams--
data science team itself,
machine learning platform,
and machine learning
infrastructure team.
Besides this organization,
there is also
validation team, which
is kind of participating
in machine learning,
data science, as well.
But they're a little bit apart.
But I will talk
about them as well.
So data science team is a
team responsible for basically
building a model itself.
They are pure data scientists,
trying not to touch any MLOps.
Then machine
learning platform is
a team that builds the
platform, as you can understand
from the name, it builds a
platform around these models
and machine learning.
So this is the
platform that is used
to run inference and
production environment and not
only production
environment on daily basis,
and deliver and basically use
the models on the production
system.
And then there is a machine
learning infrastructure team,
which is focusing on
empowering data science team
and machine learning platform
team to do their job.
So they are mostly focusing
on tools around all of this.
So that's how it looks.
And then validation
team is a team
that is responsible for
testing the models, let's say.
They are trying to see how
the models are performing
in real life or over many days
of being used in production.
So they are trying to validate
how good our models basically
are.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Great.
Yeah, thanks for sharing.
I think it's great to see that
you're really at a maturity
level where you have
different teams focused
on different parts
of the lifecycle
and really optimizing the time
to get models into production.
And you really have
great delegation
of duties across teams, here.
So we are here, again, to
talk about architecting
on Google Cloud.
So maybe you could
give us a little bit
of the story around why
you initially chose Google
Cloud a number of years ago.
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: We made this
decision around six years ago,
when we were still
a small startup.
And one of the
main reasons for it
was Google Bootcamp, Google
startup empowering program,
where Google gave
us a credit and we
were able to use Google
Cloud Platform basically
for free for a while.
This was quite a
big thing for us
because we didn't have much
money at the time, let's say.
But that was not
the only reason.
The other reason was that
Google had the great support
for Kubernetes, probably the
best at the time on the market.
And we really wanted
to be able to use
Kubernetes in our solution.
So this is reason number two.
Why are we staying with Google?
What do we like about this?
It's still the great Kubernetes
support and BigQuery,
which BigQuery is--
basically, our whole
company runs on BigQuery.
So we are tightly bound to this.
And so far it's been
working great for us.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah, thanks.
Yeah, great to hear that story.
I'm glad that FLYR Labs
is still on GCP, kind
of growing with your business.
And it feels like, really,
that big bet on BigQuery
and Kubernetes has paid
off and is really part
of your core product offering.
So now let's get into
the ML platform itself.
In addition to BigQuery
and Kubernetes,
what are some of the
other GCP services that
make up your ML platform today?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Sure.
We're using Dataflow.
We're using Vertex AI.
We are using Kubeflow
and TensorFlow.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: OK, great.
So you seem to have really
adopted some of the industry
standards and really focused
on open source, which
I think is a big core
component of Google Cloud.
As well, one of
our main objectives
is really to support
the community,
especially in the
open-source space.
So now, can you maybe talk about
the main components of your ML
architecture at a
higher level, to start?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Sure.
Three main components
are our three pipelines--
training dataset
generation pipeline,
model training pipeline, and
daily inference pipeline.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA:
Great, thanks.
Yeah, I think breaking it
down like that really makes
things a little bit clearer.
I think sometimes
architecting a broad ML
system can feel intimidating
or complex for teams.
But focusing on how data
flows through the system
with your three-pipeline
design really makes
it much more understandable.
So can you start off with the
training dataset generation
pipeline?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Of course.
Training dataset generation
demands the most resources.
So how it works-- it uses
Kubeflow as an orchestrator.
It pulls data from BigQuery.
It's usually a few years
of airline historical data.
And then it runs on Dataflow
using beam programming model.
As an output, it
generates TFRecords,
that we later put in
Google Cloud Storage
and register in our
model metadata store.
So this pipeline
is very demanding.
That's why we run
it on Google TPU.
And even though
TPU is very fast,
it still takes hours to generate
such a training dataset.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah, I think
it's somewhat common knowledge
that data preparation
is still the biggest
task within a machine
learning pipeline.
And it's interesting to kind
of hear your story resonate
with that, that it is
the most demanding and
resource-intensive part
of the entire pipeline.
So now, once you have the raw
data processed into TFRecords,
what happens then?
Can you walk us through
the training pipeline?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Yes.
Then there is another
pipeline that also uses
Kubeflow as an orchestrator.
And then it takes TFRecords
generated by previous pipeline.
It takes TFRecords from
Google Cloud Storage,
and it takes model source code,
which is just a Python package.
So it runs in Vertex
AI, and as the output
it generates a trained model
in the format of TensorFlow
SavedModel.
We put it in Google
Cloud Storage as well,
and register in model
metadata storage.
So model metadata storage,
I already mentioned it.
Let me tell you about this.
This is our internal
tool that we use for,
as you can guess from the
name, storing model metadata.
So it has models
with parameters.
And the parameters usually
include model type,
model purpose, model
ID, for which client
this model is being registered,
and on which environment
we want to use this model.
So it can be a production
model, integration model,
stage-in-development
model, and so on.
And then in this model
metadata storage,
we also keep history
of our dataset.
So it also has versions
of data set and their ID.
So later, you can
just reuse models
and reuse data sets by just
looking at the model metadata
storage.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: And
thanks for sharing that.
I think model registries
and model metadata storage
is really a interesting
topic today.
I think when you start with your
first model or your first five
models, just storing those
models in a blob storage
is sufficient.
But really, when
you scale to tens,
hundreds of models,
really developing
a specific workflow
around managing models
becomes very important
in the ML lifecycle.
So now that you have
models, of course
the next important step
is deploying those models
to run predictions.
Can you now walk us through the
final pipeline around serving?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Yes.
So this is our pipeline that
we call daily inference.
And this is actually
the pipeline
that my team is focusing on.
So this pipeline is
listening to clients' data.
So it's listening to
Pub/Subs from BigQuery,
where the client's
data is being dropped.
After we collect all
the necessary data,
the pipeline is triggered.
And as an orchestration, we
use here Argo, not Kubeflow
as in two previous pipelines.
So using Argo
Workflow, the pipeline
is being triggered and
running in Dataflow as well,
using beam programming model.
Model inference is pulling
model files from GCP,
using model metadata storage,
and data from BigQuery.
So after the
predictor is executed,
we have predictions in
form of data in BigQuery.
And then using this
data in BigQuery,
we can pack these
predictions in whatever
form our customer needs.
So for some customers, we
deliver it through the API,
and for some customers
we deliver in the form
of text files on SFTP.
So on this prediction
in BigQuery,
we also build some metrics which
are later empowering our UI,
and where analysts
from our airline can go
and check what's going on
with any specific flight
and make some decisions if they
want to adjust model outputs
or not, and if they
want to adjust prices.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: One follow-up
question-- a lot of enterprises
are looking to future proof
their platforms for scale.
So can you talk about maybe how
you've designed this platform
for the scale you expect as
you onboard new customers, more
models?
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA: Yes.
We are pretty ambitious, and
we want to serve more airlines.
So, of course,
scaling and onboarding
new customers is a
big challenge for us.
But how are we solving this?
We don't want to be a
professional services company.
We want to have one generic
solution that fits all.
Of course, it can
be configurable,
but it's still one solution.
And then when we have
every new customer,
product team-- or our
core engineering team--
don't need to do anything.
We already have the solution.
We already have
all the pipelines.
So we only need to hire a
customer-success team, which
needs to take that
data from the customer,
transform it into our
canonical data model, and then,
using the pipelines that
are already created,
start training model on
this specific customer data,
and then run this model on
our prediction pipeline.
So, basically, they're empowered
to do everything by themselves,
and core team can focus
on other features.
That's how we onboard
new customers.
It's how we scale in the amount
of the airlines we can onboard.
But also, this is not the
only challenge with scale.
And we, of course, want
to broaden our services.
And we don't want
to only predict
demand for economy
cabin, for instance.
We also want to go farther
and predict premium.
We also want to predict demand
on luggage and the [INAUDIBLE]
services you can
add to your tickets,
and then go to cargo, and so on.
So this, of course, will
result in multiple models.
So how we will scale this?
We designed the pipeline
in the way that--
where we're just able to
add as many models as we
need and run them in parallel.
So the only thing
that we will be
facing during the challenge
we'll be facing is resources.
But, of course, we can
always buy them from Google.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Great.
Thanks.
So we all know that ML platforms
are a fast evolving space.
So curious what future
enhancements you have planned.
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA:
Yeah, we have a few.
So first of all, we want to add
feature store to our tooling.
So this is something
that would allow
us to version our features
to just better manage them.
And then also, something that
would let us not generate them
on daily basis but only append.
Because historical data from
the airlines, it doesn't change.
We only get a new
portion of data every day
and for yesterday.
But, yeah, we don't need to
regenerate the entire history
to be able to run new inference.
So this is something
we've been working on.
And apart from
that, we also want
to be able to do
dynamic pricing.
And for that we will need
to add some online modelling
to our inference pipeline.
So we want to be able to
receive a request from customer
and then be able to
respond immediately
with an optimal price.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Great.
Yeah, thank you--
really exciting
roadmap, both from a
new business capability
standpoint as well as the
technology capabilities
of the ML platform.
So thank you, Ksenia, for
joining us today and sharing
what FLYR Labs does and how
you've architected an ML
platform on GCP.
KSENIA KHLYUSTINA:
Thank you so much.
MIKHAIL CHRESTKHA: Yeah, really
had a great conversation.
It's especially important that
everyone learn from each other,
as MLOps and ML platforms
are still a fairly new field.
I personally
learned a lot, and I
know many others will as well.
Everyone, if you
like this content,
please like and subscribe
to this channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]